Vsauce!
Kevin here.
At Le Refuge des Fondues in Paris, France
- wine is served in a baby bottle.
It's so cramped that you often have to walk
over the table just to get to your seat and
there are only two things on the menu - meat
of cheese.
C1 cafe in New Zealand plans to serve you
burgers at 140 km per hour.
Using a system of clear tubes, chefs will
be able to fill a stainless steel tube with
an order and send it rocketing where they'll
receive the food from the ceiling or up through
the basement.
Opaque has several locations around the U.S.
and their food is served in pitch black darkness.
Once inside you order before being seated
because you're then led to a table by holding
onto the shoulder of your server.
For the full experience pick the "surprise
me menu" so not only do you have to find your
meal, you also have to figure out what it
is you're eating.
The Twin Stars Diner in Moscow only hires
identical twins to serve to the customers
and they also dress identically while they
do it.
The concept is based on the owner's favorite
childhood movie "Kingdom of Crooked Mirrors"
where a girl looks into an alternate universe
and sees her twin.
For a fully automated meal, 's Baggers in
Germany will give your food a ride on a roller
coaster.
Sit down and choose your order from the screen
located at each table - send it to the kitchen
and then wait for it to come down the food
roller coaster.
"Black poop" and "Smells like poop" are just
a couple of the dining options available at
LA's Magic Restroom Restaurant.
Customers sit on toilets while they eat their
dinner out of toilet and urinal shaped dinnerware
with bathroom tiles and shower heads for decoration
on the wall.
Can't talk about bathroom-themed dining without
mentioning Modern Toilet a restaurant chain
based in Taiwan where diners also sit on non-working
toilets and eat and drink out of tiny toilet
bowls.
Themed restaurants are popular in Asia, and
the Alacatraz ER restaurant in Japan is purposefully
one of the creepiest.
The medical prison theme starts off with servers
dressed in nurses outfits that handcuff you
and lock you in a cell for dinner where food
and drinks are served from syringes, mannequin
heads, and test tubes.
Located in Finland the Snow Village uses 1,000
truckloads of snow are used to create the
winter wonderland.
The Ice Bar is one of the two restaurants
and the interior is made completely out of
ice and snow and food and drinks are even
served from ice sculpted bowls and glasses.
The temperature is between -2 and -5 celsius
at all times, so you have to eat in full winter
attire.
The Hajime Robot restaurant in Bangkok uses
robots to serve you food and clean up after
you.
"Hajime" means first time or beginning in
Japanese and so they named it that because
it was the first Japanese restaurant to have
robots serving food....but if serving isn't
enough they also do a little dance.
So turn out the lights, put on your winter
clothes and sit on the toilet because your
next meal might be served by identical twin
robots at 140 km/h - and as always - thanks
for watching.